President Trump will meet this morning
in Houston with family members of Santa
Fe High School shooting victims a gunman
killed eight students and two teachers
at the school about two weeks ago the
president's press secretary choked up
yesterday when a young student reporter
asked about the administration's efforts
to stop school shootings the federal
Commission on school safety meets today
in Maryland major Garrett is that the
White House was more on the story
major good morning good morning
president Trump sense of urgency on
school safety and restricting access to
some firearms has faded you spent a lot
more time lobbying the Republican
Congress on immigration for example and
his own school safety commission is off
to a slow start but today's trip to
Houston and yesterday's briefing has for
the moment put the issue of school
safety and gun control back into the
spotlight this bears been going on too
long in our country that was President
Trump less than two weeks ago after ten
people were killed at the high school in
Texas the 27th intentional school
shooting that resulted in injury or
death since mr. Trump took office at
Wednesday's White House briefing press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders got
emotional when a 13-year old student
journalists representing time for kids
asked Sanders what the administration is
doing to improve school safety
I think that as a kid and certainly as a
parent there is nothing that could be
more terrifying for a kid to go to
school and not feel safe so I'm sorry
that you feel that way
the President's Commission on school
safety will meet today this is the third
time the group will meet since it was
established by the president in the wake
of the Parkland High School shooting on
Valentine's Day
we are working very quickly to do the
work of the Commission Commission Chair
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos admitted
last week the Commission wouldn't issue
its final recommendations until the end
of the year after the high school
massacre in parkland Florida parents
pleaded for the president to do more how
many schools how many children have to
get shot the president did promise a
wide range of new school safety measures
in the aftermath of parkland but the
republican-led Congress has done little
on that front one bill to slightly
strengthen the national background check
was signed into law but more sweeping
measures on gun control or school safety
have stalled major Garrett thank you